now you're preparing for Terminator
you've gotten the role when you
determine that the robot should have
this sense of like Yul Brenner in
Westworld the robot knows how to put a
gun together what kind of training goes
into that how do you learn to put a gun
together without looking at it I mean is
this intensive training did you
blindfold yourself absolutely first you
do it without the blindfold and you do
it you know 20 times right and you have
someone helping you the you know how to
do it the best possible way and then you
put the blindfold on it and then you do
it also you know 20 times a blindfolded
and uh I think that uh the same is when
you load ammunition the same is when you
shoot you just have to do it it's all
about reps and there's one thing that I
know and that is from bodybuilding and
from weightlifting and powerlifting it's
all about reps and you took it very
seriously you didn't allow the other
actors to even interact with you during
uh off you know after you shot a scene
you try to be the robot you you said I
don't want to get to know you so well
you often decide what not so much for my
sake because I can disconnect completely
and just be the robot right but I was
worried about them that if they get
connected to me and they start looking
at me they would not look at me with the
same threat and fear I wanted to come
into the room and I wanted to have that
impact you want to intimidate impact and
intimidate and because it brings a
certain facial reaction to the to them
and I think it helps from an acting
point of view and this becomes more
believable it really is hard to play a
robot in the sense that for people to
take that for real you know what I mean
it's just really hard to pull off
because as you see now when we talk we
talk with emotions yeah they'll be of
interested there it comes from your
heart it comes from your belly and then
when we laugh you know then it's crashes
you know from inside were a Terminator
is a machine he doesn't have that inside
where things come from so all of the
dialogue comes basically from his
computer it just is spit out and without
any emotions whatsoever so you have to
keep that in mind all the time and he
always is to sell the thing that he as a
machine does not understand like when
Sarah Connor hugs him before she goes
into the time travel machine you know he
says I do not understand why do you hold
on to someone when you must let them go
yes just very cold just matter of fact
and he just doesn't understand what this
hugging is all about yes and then then
of course when he tries to be a human
being just to do a little smile or
something like that he fails miserably
yeah you know you know right away it's a
machine another human being
foreign